foreign
[Music]
skin
what color would you say that is
my color
oh says they have the worst land
possible
but they outsmart everybody the land had
oil on it
Black Gold
money flows freely here now dude load
that money sir
this wealth should come to us
their time is over
it's going to be another tragedy
when this money started coming
we should have known it came with
something else
they're like buzzards circling our
people
we're still Warriors
[Applause]
[Music]
kill these white men who killed my
family
I need you here I am right here
[Applause]
you've got to take back control of your
home
[Applause]
I was uh sent down from Washington DC to
see about these murders
see what about him
see who's doing it
[Applause]
[Music]
respect in America to make all this go
away
[Music]
you know they don't happen anymore
thank you
[Music]
Jonas we need your help
we're detecting increase the quarterback
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
man whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
foreign
we've got company
this night I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
everybody might get to the station
three massive exit who knows what else
have escaped the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
I don't know
we've never seen this before they hunted
it back
we can relax this place is magproof when
Jonas was always afraid of this but I
was also thinking
[Music]
foreign
yes it's cold swimming I don't I don't
believe you
in the shadows of arrakis lie many
Secrets
but the darkest of them all may remain
thank you the end of House of treaties
no father didn't believe in Revenge
what if Paula treaties were still alive
have you ever had a dream about your
first ride
don't try to impress anyone
you're brave we all know that
be simple be direct
nothing fancy I understand
nothing fancy
[Music]
you will never lose people on tradies
we gave them something to hope for
that's not home
my thy knife chip and shatter
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
can I come to your house today sure
I don't have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and plant choreography and a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool
it's the best day ever it is the best
day ever so is yesterday and so is
tomorrow and every day for now until
forever
you guys ever think about dying
when my heart breaks some things have
been happening that might be related
cold shower falling off my roof and my
heels are on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
what do I have to do you have to go to
the real world
you can go back to your regular life or
you can know the truth about the
universe choice is
n't that the first one the high heel you
have to want to know okay do it again
[Music]
coming with you okay
wow this is the real world what's going
on why are these men looking at me yeah
they're also staring at me
[Music]
in the real world that's impossible if
this got out this could mean extremely
weird things for our world this would be
catastrophic
played with Barbie since we were like
five years old
no one rests until this doll is back in
a box
[Music]
humans only have one ending get that
Barbie I
[Music]
mean forever
no I won't let you do just one
appendectomy but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor I need a clicky pen
No a sharp thing no there he is Doctor
somebody get security
[Music]
is Bobby [__] if you're still in doubt
we're in a race against the Nazis
[Music]
they have a 12-month Head Start 18. how
could you possibly know that
we've got one hope
all America's industrial might and
scientific innovation connected here
secret Laboratory
and keep everyone there until it's done
let's go recruit some scientists
build a town build it fast we don't let
scientists bring their families will
never get the best
why would we go to the middle of nowhere
for who knows how long
why why
because this is the most important thing
to ever happen in the history of the
world
you're the great improviser but this
you can't do in your head
are we saying there's a chance that when
we push that button we destroy the world
chances are near zero
near zero what do you want for Theory
alone zero would be nice
[Music]
a matter of life and death
but I can perform this miracle
World War II would be over our boys
would come home
that's happening isn't it
the world
well remember this day
I work here will ensure peace mankind
has never seen
[Music]
until somebody builds a bigger one
you are the man who gave them the power
to destroy themselves
and the world is not prepared
hey
seven
six five
four
three Truman needs to know what's next
what's next
oh
welcome home honey
do you read now what is this it's
classified
you weren't invited
they call it bad behavior
hey why are you here I got this
situation when I need your help I need
bad friends
what's up the new guy is that sniper
don't worry about it I got a
prescription oh guys remember this face
I'll shoot it by accident
terrorists have taken possession of
nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off the
coast
if these babies go off
it'll be World War III
to choose this life over friends
over family
time to get loud
let's fly baby
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about
oh it's way bigger than that
foreign
[Music]
something doesn't feel right
so if you what happened
there's something here
that's not meant to be
[Applause]
what are you doing
she's standing in everything
this thing it's come back for me
this demon was once an angel
rejected by God
stripped with power
it wants that power back
it's okay to be scared I'm scared too
you send that thing back to hell
[Music]
[Applause]
my view
[Music]
nine seconds
that's what I'll give you to decide your
fate
[Music]
what did you do back home
government work I'm retired
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real people and I'm starting
to believe
this is where I'm supposed to be
what happens here happens to you many
times
I should say out of other people's
business whatever it is you and your
friends do do it somewhere else you
warning me I'm preparing is that a Timex
no it's a boost that's the median nerve
that I'm compressed
that's a level three you don't want it
to go to a level four
[Music]
seem like a man who understands violence
like this place you can't take that from
me
that can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily did you kill him
[Music]
nine seconds
do I look like a killer
[Music]
oh
Our Lives
are the sum of our choices
[Music]
not escape the past
Ethan this mission of yours
is gonna cost you
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing whoa
it's been a long time for him
you've no idea the power I represent
it knows your story and How It Ends
listen to me
the world's coming after you
his fate is written
shall we write yours too if anything
happens to them there's no place that I
won't go to kill you that is written
[Applause]
Ethan what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that
[Music]
[Applause]
my son never show Mercy we
are predators
boys your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind
you'll know my business yes
power is about strength
if you show weakness you will give our
enemies an opening
[Applause]
foreign
like his mother leave him
what happened that day
I stared death in the face and for the
first time I saw my true self
tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off the six of us
and only one of you there's six of you
now
[Music]
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
I think you're some kind of honored you
were exactly like our father just
another man hunting for a trophy
the murderers
isn't that what he taught us
you don't get to do that to me anymore
Mr tagline
Mr tackling
where's Mr tagley oh you're standing in
him
you're a goddamn lunatic oh you just
figured that out now
there is an animal I need to wind up
fast don't you want to know why they
call me the rhino
thank you
hi this is Mike I was just calling to
see if that job that you offered was
still available yes
security guard I will take anything
this place was huge in the 80s with the
kids they shut it down years ago the
owners just not ready to let it go yet I
will work and you will sleep I
understand
thank you
all you have to do
is keep your eyes on the monitor
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's where
fantasy and fun come to life
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
we must be new security guard can I uh
help you officer have you met them yet
[Applause]
who
damn
[Music]
in the 80s kids went missing
the police searched Freddy's top to
bottom hello
they never found them
that's why the play shut down
there are ghost children possessing
giant robots
thanks for the heads up
technically they're animatronics
what do they want they want to make her
like them Bobby
tell me how to stop them
too late
where to
why do I always get the weirdos
what's happened
it's a peaceful place in the sky
are you going to listen
no
why not
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven
[Music]
years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
as long as AI is a threat
we will never stop hunting mountains
this is a fight for our very existence
whatever's in there they're sure worried
about someone getting in
yeah we're getting out
[Music]
we're just saying we can't go to heaven
because you're not good
[Music]
and I'm not a person
to locate the weapon yeah it's a key
belts
[Music]
we are this close to winning a war
execute her or we go extinct
they're coming to get me
[Applause]
oh you want to start
from the beginning
people
coming together
[Music]
[Applause]
you know you're a superstar
I'm a superstar
[Applause]
the music and the message
and what is the message
peace oh life is worth much more than
gold
Bob they try to kill you and your wife
and now you're choosing to return to
Jamaica to play a peace concert
don't you fear for your life
[Music]
my life is not important to me
do you really think this world will make
it
yes
there's no way
[Music]
[Applause]
we know where we'll go
[Music]
foreign
destiny
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
[__] him out of it
don't use that word that way I mean
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that
[Music]
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rap
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we think I'm
super fun and then everyone will think
we're cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
that's a little tortoises huh I can't
believe there are other mutants you want
to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dunk
okay
my son Michelangelo you have heart
Donatello you have wisdom Rafael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage it's not a
problem
excuse me Mr Reyes
he finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
so how to reach you always land on your
feet bro you're hymen
they don't get that much
but do not open it you went in to get us
jobs and all you brought back was a
hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked what the hell is that
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
oh
re-entry systems ready
it's some kind of world destroying a
weapon it's designed to protect the
toast
sometimes it does what you want and
sometimes it does it
I think I got a bus in half
the Scarab chose you
it belongs to me
hello you feel for your family
makes you weak
[Music]
the universe has sent you a gift and you
have to figure out what you're going to
do with it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
let's party
nice choice
it's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist
[Music]
foreign
community
[Music]
room
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean casca High bottom
I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray bear
[Music]
there has been a change this year as a
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
survivors
what does my mentor do besides bring me
roses I do my best to take care of you
you really want to take care of me in
that Arena
start by thinking I can actually win
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games
[Music]
enjoy the show
what happens in there
filled with the terror becoming coming
prey
they'll quickly we become predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
foreign
[Music]
across that line into evil
you hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
falling
how wonderful that we all get to be here
for someone's final performance
everything is about winning
come on
it's the things we love most but Try Us
Captain Rambo
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
hello hello
[Applause]
[Music]
where's Captain Rambo
oh
[Music]
hi we're looking for kamalakon
[Applause]
okay so our powers are entangled I can
manipulate light energy and you I could
totally show you
hi where's our daughter wherever you
were
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God
we're a team no no no we're not we're
not a team
[Music]
are you ready we're ready to forget the
further once and for all
[Music]
my brain just been foggy past few years
all I ever wanted was to be a good dad
adulting
[Music]
did you ever try and get help I'm just
trying to push through
College you still have a few weeks
before your students show up right just
an idea to reconnect I know it's been
tough with you too
[Music]
the balance of light and dark is what
we're after you're an art school I take
it yeah you go here too yes
draw and experience that defines you
when I was 10.
it's in a coma
but I don't even remember being sick
sink deep into your memory
and let's see what the light we can find
I'm seeing crazy stuff
I think these drawings could be Clues
from my past
which you don't know and I was too
scared to tell you the truth our family
has been keeping secrets they suppressed
our memories but I can still feel
something following us there's only one
way to find out
foreign
I feel like I'm getting closer to
something
's getting closer to me
when you awaken the Dead the further you
travel the riskier your journey will
become
are you gonna answer that
it's not mine
[Music]
sorry who is this
do I have your attention that I do
something to you you sound so guilty
what do you want drive to this location
honey Something's Happened there's a man
who's put a bomb in the car under our
seats there are pressure triggers
we can't get up the car will explode
we're here listen very carefully or I
kill you open the glove box
why are you doing this what have I ever
done to you this life or yours Matt I'm
your best friend
[Music]
You're a murderer Now Matt
you think I'm the bomber
well I guess you've had a tough day
I know that you've lost a lot of money
for your clients who invested in your
fund
thank you a lot of people are worried
about you
[Music]
you've got everybody's attention man
it's all out there
[Music]
a [__] I will kill you
What's it gonna be
Drive
when our world is threatened one team is
ready to launch does he say lunch uh no
I said launch
[Music]
it's giving off some kind of energy
I didn't do it
no way this September I think we've got
super powers
and that's why I wear a hard hat
[Music]
look at your paws
right now the clumsy pup shoots
Fireballs out of his paws
Paw Patrol but more but just a little
bit extra
how about
the mighty pups
supposed to be my superpowers
I'm gonna take them one by one
oh my goodness I could Buck
I have so much to say give me that
it's showtime
Dinger it looks different than I
remember
can you go up against one of us
you go up against all of us
now that we're super I'm never gonna get
to sleep well you're probably more tired
than you
oh you've got to be kidding me
[Music]
hello Watson we try to think about the
floor
oh
of course naturally
[Music]
foreign
used to being one of the leaders in my
last job I was determined to build up
the same position at work that's how the
coffee machine works this is how the
blinds work
whenever anyone looked at me I fired off
a broad smile
a smile disarms your opponent and makes
them doubt their own enmity I stuck to
my schedule when I first discovered the
room
there was something special about this
place
answer me truthfully what is this room
for don't drag me into this I found a
secret room and when I work in there I'm
able to do anything a secret room it's
just that most people aren't able to see
it
were you on drugs
what are you doing when you stand like
that
what are you talking about
can't do what that's about it's very
strange I say fire him if he's allowed
to stand there like that then I should
be allowed to practice Reiki in the
break area
there is no room Austin didn't I tell
you it was pointless to try and conduct
psychological warfare against me you
have secrets hidden in there that for
whatever reason you don't want me to see
but he's mental anyone can see that
it's a bit different from the other
people here I can tell Larson want to
tell me how far in advance all of this
worked out was I even one of the
original intended victims what exactly
is it that you want I just want to do my
job I don't care about you you're a
number in a column on a spreadsheet I
could view the world as something
ominous or
I could choose to see the light
I chose to see the light
[Music]
do you know what the greatest thing
about America is you can make things
happen here like nowhere else
[Music]
you can do anything
you want to sell high-end stuffed
Himalayan cats understuffed actually for
greater posability we're professionals
we're giving the people what they need
did you see the latest numbers we broke
the entire internet thing
oh big or you go home
[Music]
I would tell you he did it all
which is as crazy as believing stuffed
animals are gold
do you see the truck crash insane
poor beanies
this has always been my company company
we created together I have to be so
dramatic I mean my salary's been reduced
75 yeah I'm just doing what's necessary
you know running the real actual
business over here
[Music]
my life is this company can I see where
it's going wow there are signs of real
trouble genius is one percent
inspiration 99 presentation
it's not how the saying goes
everything good that's happened to me is
because of you guys we are bonded
forever
have you considered poisoning him
countless times
[Music]
I have our perfect Partners lined up Joe
is with us the greatest one-on-one
salesman in the world how brilliant is
that
[Music]
um
please
I only want to speak to Oprah Winfrey
has she reached out
oh
[Music]
for centuries we have called out to the
universe
looking for answers
[Music]
the universe
calls back
us your leader
[Music]
[Applause]
hi can you hear me honey now is a really
bad time okay
bye I love you I love you I love you
[Music]
this is new
please State the name of your Homeworld
uh Earth welcome leader of Earth
we are the United Advanced species of
the Universe I think there's been a
mistake you're not the leader of Earth
sorry for the mix-up commence memory
wipes
I am the leader of Earth
why is your voice different
uh I've always talked like this since I
was a kid which I'm obviously not
anymore but yes I run the planet the
trial of Earth can proceed uh-oh until
then as you say on Earth okay bye I love
you okay okay
foreign
[Music]
but in moments of great success I regret
it that's a thing for your species no
just a me thing everyone was shocked
[Music]
I will tell you I've never seen anything
like it holy
is the craziest I think I've ever seen
everything okay
oh language the baby's here
yo what up everybody roaring Kitty here
I'm gonna pick a stock and talk about
why I think it's interesting and that
stock is Gamestop I love this guy
retail Traders hooked him to GameStop I
think they think it's a good investment
it looks like there's one guy driving
all the buying
the money man happy to take it
Wall Street is betting that this company
is gonna fail if it fails these hedge
fund people make a ton of money 70
000 people have watched this video
[Music]
if he's in I'm in if he's in I'm in
GameStop those shares not stopping don't
stop it's only going to go up when they
hit I'm gonna buy you a mansion
let's ring to that my brother is a nerd
Wall Street must be seeing this right
you should probably dial in holy [__] do
you have a minute I uh
um
babe how much did we make today
5 million how much did we lose today a
billion and yesterday four million and
yesterday a billion
yeah
really
you got rich dudes pissing in their
pants right now they're coming after you
we need to talk about the Game Stop
situation
you tell Traders always lose you've been
served Wall Street cheated
surprise surprise you have to testify
before Congress the game has changed
[Music]
what's the point of winning the race if
you let some idiots steal the prize a
lot of people feel the system is broken
the whole idea of the stock market is if
you're smart and maybe with a little
luck you can make your fortune certainly
not anymore
there's no hope for the little guy
thank you
[__] balls
maybe now there is yeah
[Music]
best friends trip this is gonna be
iconic
you do understand this is a work trip
for me Audrey I got you look at me
you're thinking about a dick damn it
you're right look at me look at me look
at me now I love a grand Adventure I
heard that if you keep up with Chinese
businessmen they respect you more
is it a condom you look like you've had
a lot of things in your [__] not a
lot of things just one thing but many
different varieties of that one thing
look at me look at me look at me
the stuffed bear
so powerful if you do not know where you
come from how do you know who you are
I'm just a garbage American who only
speaks English and a little Golem
do you guys have that here yeah we have
it's the all over the world
let's just be adults are you horny
sex isn't shameful it's beautiful like
the noises oh
show them there's some boards in this
house there's some boards in this house
I'm not racist you don't like Boba and
you never [__] an Asian guys damn
still when I masturbate I sometimes
fantasize about Splinter he's Asian he's
a rat he's a good father
I'm doing it again tonight
huh
no please what's my mom's Remembrance
Day I just want to forget about it huh
[Music]
[Applause]
cannot go for more than 90 seconds am I
clear what happens after 90 seconds
don't wanna stay
foreign
blow it out to close it
put your hand on it
now say
talk to me
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me
what did the hand feel like
it felt amazing I can't see and feel
everything on the other side
I'll tell my mom she was trying to reach
out
I'm here
still been seeing stuff you've been
saying stuff
what if we open the door but we didn't
shut it
oh my God they followed us
I like him they're not gonna stop you're
never gonna stop
I like you
hi hey
Tashi Duncan she's gonna turn a whole
family into millionaires
should I have a fashion line a
foundation
[Music]
you were credible today thank you I mean
it wasn't even like tennis it was an
entirely different day
hey come hang out with us later let me
come tuck you in no we just keep talking
[Music]
does this happen going after the same
girl not as often as you think we
usually have different types so you're
saying I should be flattered aren't you
everybody's type
come here which one of us
[Music]
he's not in love with you
what makes you think I want someone to
be in love with me it's nice to see lit
up about something even if it's my
girlfriend
or it's got his coach Tashi Donaldson
who also is his wife I'm playing for
both of us Tashi
I think maybe we're disturbed by the
fact that she could have been in a salon
like me when we were teenagers when we
were teenagers hey I love you
I know
you don't know what tennis is
it's a relationship
we went somewhere really beautiful
together
I'm taking such good care of my little
white boys
I assume you planned this not this part
[Music]
I like it
today I teach at times about a place
called Africa
you say our mom has come from Queens
over there
that means that we
royalty
[Music]
you don't love me afternoon
even if we have the part you and me just
have one heart
[Music]
you I'll write you every day
nothing protecting keep me from it
you mustn't got no Kinfolk around these
parts all I had was my sister
she was the only one ever loved me
it's time for you to see the world
there's gonna be some changes made put
it on this ain't me hush we need to look
like we belong let's see the smile and
color oh sweet and loving God
to God
now we're talking
[Music]
dear Celie we have more than just kings
and queens
here at the center of the universe
thank you
the Demeter on Charter from Romania to
London
shipping private crates
tense unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
this year's comments he's a doctor
we dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I know my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay a
bonus for timely arrival number
let me show you the ship this here is
huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give the
US clear
the fan belt No Doubt
[Applause]
something right about the animals
all the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil is on board
[Music]
powerful evil
in night it drinks our blood he's just
like
we call him Dracula
[Applause]
the world is a man he's coming
see the size of that bloody thing
[Music]
he is on this ship which piece that we
will never leave
the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
this is Bella
Bella this is Mr McCandless hello fella
thank you
no she's an experiment good evening and
rain and her body are not quite
synchronized
but she's progressing at an accelerated
piece
[Music]
tell me where did she come from
I shall
or it is a happy tail
[Music]
I am Bella Baxter and there is a world
to enjoy circumnavigate it is the goal
of all to progress grow a woman plotting
her course to freedom I did not fall
[Music]
oh
who do you think the best driver is
probably Rory I would dust him in a lab
yeah all you do is sleep video games
with some crazy dreams of racing cars
Doug you're the one that told us always
do something we love you know what
racing cars cost
look around it's not our world son
what is this it's a contest
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world get a chance to compete in
professional racing dude this is real
[Applause]
is real
I'm sorry I really think you're gonna
take a kid who plays video games in
their bedroom you're gonna strap them to
a 200 mile an hour rocket it'll tear
them to pieces
it's not gonna work the guys who race
are Elite athletes but I won't stop now
your kids are scrawny little gamer kids
well that's why you coming come on let's
go
must be a new experience for you moving
your legs
you puked on my lawn there's no turning
back now when you're in a race the
cockpit is going to be 140 degrees
Fahrenheit
g-forces will be twice what an astronaut
experiences I can't see anything
hey you get extra points for that in the
game Jesus Jesus Christ
surfing nerds that you sent me he is the
best one
[Music]
welcome to Team Nissan
what's next it's a major leagues the
other drivers are going to hate
[Music]
you'll probably like smart of the game
it's called racing
if you missed the line in the game you
reset you miss it on the track
you could die
all right
I know this track
I've raced it a thousand times
that's what I'm talking about
come on guys
we're gonna be late for the royal
wedding let's go get married what I mean
let's give Bridgette and Crystal married
yeah oh cause it would be weird if we
got married yeah wow
oh boy that was a crazy bachelor party
uh Cloud guy don't feel so good
tiny diamond you make the cutest Little
Flower Boy
come on Daddy I'm the cutest Little
Flower Man
we are gathered here today
I'm John Dory branches long lost brother
calling me
you're the guy from Frozone we were just
listening to them
but that's all in the past
how come you never told me you had a
secret brother correction used to be my
brother
my brothers walked out on me and never
came back Branch we're out of sync we've
gone from Boys to Men and now there's
only one direction for us to go the back
streets Bridge it's time we find the
rest of our brothers and get the band
back together we're gonna have the best
family reunion ever grow zone 2.0 Rosa
reunion froze on Here We Grow Again
Frozone where'd they grow I don't know
[Music]
tiny Bridge poppy in this random dude on
another Musical Adventure oh hey tiny
you see that button right there oh you
mean the button is taking every fiber
about being not depressed
oh
[Music]
wow too much hustle is a thing
huh look at that
[Music]
the K Santos
not on your life
hello girls
[Music]
last body shot competition so we are
gonna salt you up I've had it with love
I don't believe it's relevant to the
21st century lesbian
you're not wearing that I just came from
work I came from Toledo I don't dress
like it I'm not here to Pedal my Wares
I'm leaving town I am too that was my
plan where are you going Tallahassee
Florida I've been unhappy that's why we
take this trip together huh babe we get
our act together together
Curly's Drive Away Pennsylvania's most
trusted name in car delivery come on
here don't call me curly
and your name curly my name is Curly we
just met it's too familiar
we're here for the car wait a minute you
call with a drop off in Tallahassee and
then these broads come in and say
they're ready to go to Tallahassee
they drive the car instead of you is
that bad bad if they find the goods
what we should see what's in here I bet
it's locked
foreign
[Applause]
I understand that you're unhappy sir we
will find and deliver the package we
just want your friends
you cannot relate to the public which in
the service profession is a big handicap
did the two creeps find you they know we
have their stuff maybe we sell it back
shake them down are they like wanted or
something oh no they're not in trouble
at all I'm gonna help you break a big
murder case that is about the dumbest
thing I've ever heard and I'm a cop
here
who are you Democrats
wow you've had a full day
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you have to do is give your wish
to me
I wish
[Music]
what was that
what were you doing
[Music]
it didn't work when does the magic
happen huh
I'm talking I am talking who knew my
voice would be this low
[Music]
wait
I should warn you before you step inside
the house this could change the course
of your entire life I'm not afraid of a
couple goes
you say that now
this Mansion is unhinged
these ghosts definitely don't want to
leave
death lurks around every corner
foreign
God give us a break there's so many bad
people in the world haunt them amen
I do like surprises is anybody else
seeing this
we're gonna fight whether we like it or
not or else we're stuck here for
eternity
if this comes down to an exorcism
trouble
for one more
Fran was mugged he was tall he had hair
that was sticking out of a what a top
hat yup Top Hat yes yes Top Hat you
would pull a rabbit out of it probably
uh eyes they were a bit uh
raccoon they sit back
and he was smiling like yeah like that
exactly is this the man who mugged you
wow you just did that just now
it's known as the beautiful game but
let's face it it's a complicated game
guys soccer as you like to call it is
like life next season I think we have a
real shot
I'm sorry uh Thomas did nobody tell you
you're you're fired
good news is you got two options option
one that's where you're currently at or
American Samoa you serious
we haven't scored one goal in the
history of our country trying to have a
soccer team
start again humiliation mark my words
things are going to change I got us a
new coach
something to drink whiskey beer wine yep
we got all those which one whiskey beer
and wine
thank you so much
it's safe to say you have zero Talent OR
understanding of the game
I'm right about the sky what he is white
coach you got the toughest job on the
island
what we want is just one goal one goal
come on guys we've worked too long and
hard for this you've only been here a
few days
I can't work with these guys for them
it's like some sort of game
that's it giant leadership now we're
making some progress
thank you for sending us Mr rongan we've
become quite attached to him it's like
finding a little lost white kid at the
mall and telling him which way to go
[Applause]
will you read us a bedtime story okay
get this over with three little kittens
with fur all brushed said we can't sleep
we feel too rushed wow this is garbage
do you actually like this illumination
this the studio that Grant you
Despicable Me
The Secret Life of pets
feel heroic and handsome
I'm a little wet but I still look good
the Grinch
You're a Mean One Mister sing
oh yes I'm fine thank you
how are you minions
[Applause]
and the Super Mario Brothers movie
there's a huge Universe out there
this Christmas illumination brings you a
film for the entire family
here we go
portion
swing deploy
let's fly
migration
We're not gonna make it are we Uncle Dan
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
assistant what about boys at school ones
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
everyone who ever lived here Falls
victim to some tragedy
like her daughter a year ago
my daughter was my whole life
to hear her voice again
I will give all I have
if someone wants to be heard
[Music]
we are here
that woman called the spirits and they
answered
you saw what I saw for once in your life
admit that you were up against something
bigger than you
tonight we are all afraid
we cannot hide from our ghosts
whether they are real or not
could the ugly untalented gays please
report to the principal's office yes
that's you guys
tonight is our night we're getting the
couch I'm gonna talk to Brittany you
could say how to Isabelle what would I
say hey girl how's your boyfriend how's
his penis
Bell you both for committing a crime
against Jeff get out of the car
[Music]
for a self-defense it's like a Fight
Club yes yes stay in your lane until
you're munching beavert Wesleyan yes sir
what's your plan here Jefferson
and they're picking on the weak and
defenseless so we teach a bunch of girls
how to defend themselves they are
grateful to us adrenaline is Flowing
next thing you know Isabelle and
Brittany are kissing us on the mouse
India Club advisor you know my mom did
say I need to pick up a hobby
Welcome to our [__] fight club let's
get it popping in this [__]
[Applause]
I have a safe space like this it means a
lot to people I'm gonna finally reverse
stock my stalker yeah I'll be able to
kill my stepdad awesome
seems so supportive of women especially
the hot ones man-made therapy
are you cheating on me no I literally
saw you yesterday so nerd I [__] your
mom
we are literally at the bottom you have
nowhere to go but up
your Club is over
they deserve a shot at showing everybody
how [__] cool they are
on that trophy you created a Fight Club
to get some coaching I don't even know
how to park that thing I know y'all
ain't tickling the Pearl I just don't
know if you're supposed to be talking to
us like that just like as a teacher
I take the trigger fingers from all my
prisoners it's less likely to shoot me
in the back
you don't have any business here this is
my business lock them up you are gonna
hang for this what happened to you
see right now
[Music]
dead men strung to Your Wagon those men
threatened to rape my wife
mayor's gonna want to talk to you
mayor Thomas where's he at Bishop's
mayor now
hello Roy I missed you by a day in
Galveston three young men are dead there
I didn't kill no one get your facts
straight friend
let's go not today I ain't asking Sid
not today I've just been giving news
that my brother was murdered I'm gonna
give you one day in honor of your
brother don't play games with me get out
of town they're going to shrink you up
for killing the Man's brother we gotta
get the hell out of here you wanna join
[Music]
you win you walk out of here live lose
it's your judgment day show
[Music]
do it better
[Applause]
oh you will pay for this mess you killed
man of the law and there ain't no
clemency for that
Reno's back not for Revenge
Dead or Alive Bishop's got 50 men
securing that mind that's how you four
gonna do you can use your help
ah
back on your horse and let's finish this
foreign
[Music]
I was practically the only non-white
person in my entire high school and you
never felt discriminated again I
definitely did but not because I was
Asian because of your inherent bad
personality exactly
do you remember that internship that I
applied for what about it it's
New York is overrated it's so gentrified
now how many times have you even been
there are we counting layovers
yeah
you always assume the worst about me and
then you end up acting crazy over
nothing I'm not acting crazy so stop
using that word
you're just proving my point
you two like broken up we're taking some
time off while the cat's away the mouse
will play with himself probably
can I kiss you
sorry I'm a little out of practice
it's clear
[Music]
I'm gonna go to New York listen maybe
you could come with me I thought you
came out here to clear your head I did
and then I met Meredith and I've been
there ever since so when are you gonna
see her I mean I'm here to see Miko
she's an intern here actually I'm the
only intern here you
have problems with anger depression your
weird selfish you could
[Music]
best thing
I know you're going to want to blame
this on society or on your race or
whatever but this really is just about
you this is your rock bottom
you doing with that guy you're being
adorable
to meet you mysterious
is anyone sitting here no
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I heard it again
no more nightmares tonight good champ
[Music]
this is getting ridiculous
this is an old house
there's bound to be bumps in the night
Peter Drew this yes is he all right
Peter has an overactive imagination
[Music]
no
that's right
you know I wish I had someone I could
talk to about the things that were
happening in my house
[Music]
[Applause]
mom
[Music]
Peter sometimes
you have to make hard decisions to
protect your family
what is that
the banging
[Music]
all right
you don't hear anything Peter
it's going to get you into trouble one
day
[Music]
happen since My Big Fat Greek Wedding
my father passed away and his last wish
was for us to visit his childhood
Village and reconnect with our Roots so
we're having a reunion or corned Greece
oh yeah
[Music]
and by Lee I mean
the whole family oh I'm so lucky paging
so lucky anybody by the name of sulaki
on his flight
Aristotle what I didn't know you were
going to be here you're doing here I had
an amazing date
she ghosted him
[Music]
we are related to your public
who was married to my great great Yaya
sister sistelina
thank you I will be your favorite
I promised my dad I would find his best
friends I know them do they still live
here no how do we find them they will
come for the reunion did they tell you
they're coming no
they're bedrooms family sleepover
we'll never forget do you know man no I
am surprised but I am not surprised
because I'm never surprised
[Music]
I really need to find my dad's friends
Angelo and I are on it okay bye
all in your eyes
let's do it
I'm calling it you got us back to Greece
you're the head of the family now I
can't really Day drink like this don't
worry a lady is never drunk
pick the one we have for dinner oh thank
you uh I'm a vegetarian
no
[Music]
we got these problems